president Trump confirms a high-ranking
North Korean official will come to the
US for talks about a possible summit
with Kim jong-un Kim Young Cheol was
seen in the Beijing Airport early this
morning and this morning the president
Trump tweeted the Vice Chairman is
heading now to New York Ben Tracy was
just in North Korea he's back and now
following the developments from Beijing
Ben good morning good to see you good
morning so this appears to be yet
another sign that both the White House
and the North Koreans really want this
summit to happen on June 12th now kim
yeongcheol is a very senior member of
North Korea's Workers Party he was the
former military spy chief of North Korea
and he was also at Kim jong-un side this
past weekend during that surprise summit
between the leaders of North and South
Korea he was also dispatched the south
during the Olympics earlier this year
now kim yeong-cheol is likely coming to
the u.s. to work on the agenda for this
summit and his visit would be seen as
equal to Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
s recent visits to North Korea meanwhile
two American delegations are working
overseas with their North Korean
counterparts on the summit one group was
seen departing its hotel in Seoul today
for meetings on the North Korean side of
the Demilitarized Zone while another is
in Singapore the site of the summit
working on logistical issues now despite
all of this the White House has not
officially said that this summit is
actually back on as you may recall
President Trump canceled it last week
John and Tracy and Beijing tanks